معنا الان حول هذا الموضوع منك يابا
العقيد يوري هناك المتحدث باسم القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه نرحب بك العقيد يوري
هناك نود ان نستوضح منكم الاليات التي
سيتم بموجبها تزويد اوكرانيا بمقاتله اف
16 بعد اعلان الدنمارك عن موافقه امريكا
لهاولندا على تزويد اوكرانيا بذلك
يومكم سعيد ان الاليات التي تسالين عنها
باختصار بسيطه جدا
هناك الكثير من الطائرات مثل اف سته عشر
وغيرها التي اعلنا عن ضرورتها لنا منذ
بدايه الاجتياح الشامل الروسي بل اقول
اضافه انه منذ بدايه عام
2020 كانت هذه الامور مسجله قبل سنوات من
الاجتياح الروسي ان الاعتماد على الطائرات
السوفييتيه شيء صعب
انها طائرات قديمه
ولذلك
نحن نسير
وثوق الى
الكثير مما مررنا به كاعمال سياسيه وغيرها
الدبلوماسيه حتى في نهايه النهايه يحدث
هذا العمل التاريخي ان الاليات هي كالتالي
سوف نحصل على بعض الطائرات من الدول التي
اعلنت هذا هولندا والدنمارك التي
تريد ان تجدد اسطولها باف 35
وثم ايضا الولايات المتحده قدمت الاخضر
انها لا تعارض هذا الشيء الثاني هو تدريب
طيارين الذي يجب ان ينتهي في الصيف القادم
واعتقد ان هذا سوف يتم اعلانه قريبا وسوف
يكون هناك تدريب جديد لطيارين جدد وايضا
للفريق الهندسي الذي سوف يعمل على صيانه
الطيارات بهذه الطريقه نحن نعتقد اننا سوف
نقوم بان الانتقال الى مرحله
هي مرحله الطيارين والمعدات وفريق
الهندسيين عندها سوف يتعرض الروس لضغط
شديد من ظهور هذه الطائرات التي سوف تقوم
بتغيير شكل الحرب وهذا ما نعتمد عليه لان
اوكرانيا تريد ان تحرر جميع اراضيها تقول
الولايات المتحده اعطت الضوء الاخطر ليس
هدف حسب بعد موافقتها للدنمارك وهولندا
اعلى ارسال طائره اف 16 وتزويد اوكرانيا
بها قبل قليل مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي
يعلن بان مشاورات تجري في الكونغرس ايضا
على تزويد اوكرانيا بطائرات اف 16 ماذا
تتوقعون من هذه المشاورات
ان الطائرات
الاوكرانيه التي نحتاجها
هي امور مهمه جدا ومن الواضح ان الطائرات
التي سوف تقدمها هولندا هو امور غير كافيه
نحتاج لاستبدال الاسطول السوفيتي الجوي
تماما يجب ان نقوم باستبدال المعدات
المنتجه
ولذلك سوف نحتاج المزيد من هذه الطائرات
كما سنحتاج
لشركات
ماركتين
التي تخدم هذه المعدات هذا يعني اننا سوف
نحتاج لخدمات تؤمن هذه الطائرات وهذه امور
يجب ان ينص عليها في الاتفاقات لذلك نحن
نحتاج من الولايات المتحده ليست طائرات
فقط بل نحتاج للبنيه التحتيه ومجموعه
كامله وشامله لكل
قدرات
والمعدات معدات التحكم ونحتاج
للصواريخ
المجنحه والموجهه هناك عشرات من المعدات
الاضافيه
نحن لا نحتاج لهذه الطائرات للطيران بها
فقط بل نحتاج امكانيات وقدرات هجوميه
لتحرير اراضينا ولذلك سوف نحتاج لكل
الاسلحه التي تدعمها هذه الطائرات وهذا
شيء في المستقبل سوف نتحدث عنه لا نحتاج
ضوء ضوء اخضر فقط بل نحتاج للدعم بجميع
هذه الانواع من المعدات دعنا نضيف الى
عنصر التغيير والتبديل الاجهزه والمعدات
السوفيتيه باخرى شرط اخر
يسبق عمليه التزويد وهو تدريب الطيارين
الى اين وصلت عمليه تدريب الطيارين
الاوكرانيين على استخدام هذا النوع من
الطائرات
دعونا نبدا من ان بعض
بعض الاسلحه الامريكيه بدانا باستبدالها
فعلا وتعلمنا استخدامها مثل الصواريخ
المختلفه ولدينا خبره باستخدام هذه
الصواريخ ولكن هذه الصواريخ ليست فعاله
كافيا اذا كنا ما اذا كنا نستخدمها
بالطائرات الامريكيه هذا سيكون اعلى
فعاليه نحن نقوم بواجباتنا في تدريب
الطيارين
ونقوم بتعليمهم حتى بالجانب النظري وهذا
في ظروف هم هؤلاء الطائرين الان يقوموا
بمهمات عسكريه وفي نفس الوقت يتدرب كما
وان
الطيارين يضطروا اتخاذ دورات باللغه
الانجليزيه حتى يتدربوا من خبراء امريكيين
ولكننا لدينا مجموعه من الطيارين الذين
سوف يكون في المستقبل القريب حاضرين
للبدء في هذا التدريب
ولذلك ايضا سوف نحتاج لمطارات متخصصه
للتدرب على هذه
الطيارات ان الطيارات السوفييتيه الموجوده
لدينا نستخدمها من مطاراتنا
فهذه
المطارات
تساعدنا ان نقوم
بالمهمات بنجاح والحفاظ على الطيارات ايضا
ولذلك الطائرات الغربيه والامريكيه
سوف نستخدمها بطريقه فعاله وسوف نحافظ على
امنها ايضا وهذه بنيه تحتيه اضافيه نحن
بحاجاتها ولكن
الطيارين يتدربون يتدربون الان ولدينا
مجموعات قد تعود في اقرب فرصه ممكنه شكرا
المتحدث
باسم القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه